well we're six months away from a return
to the dangerzone top come maverick was
actually supposed to be released today
but because of the corona virus it was
pushed back to December but trust me
when I tell you it will be worth the
wait
good morning Aviators this is your
captain speaking
today's exercise is dogfighting the
student becomes the teacher and Top Gun
maverick but what else should we expect
from the sequel it's one of life's
mysteries sir and look I can't talk
about the story at all at this point I
could tell you but then I'd have to kill
you okay Tom we get it you want to keep
it a surprise but we have some Intel
like Jennifer Connelly's character has a
connection to this line from the
original film son your ego is writing
checks your body can't cash high speed
passes over five air control towers and
one Admirals daughter
Benjamin yep there's rumors Connelly is
that Admirals daughter and Tom rekindled
the romance Tom he always wants to top
himself did he just go crazy this time
he sets the bar high everything he does
he's like just pushing himself going
further and further it's it's it's
really extraordinary J Ellis plays one
of Mavs students we did about 40 hours
of flight training Tom completely
created our entire flight curriculum I
am so proud of them than what they've
done and it is heavy duty
could be my wingman anytime val kilmer
recently revealed in his autobiography
that he begged to be a part of maverick
Cruz went for it
the reunion felt great he wrote but fans
have been speculating just how involved
Iceman is one hint from the trailer is
the pin maverick placed on the coffin
the same pin Kilmer worn the original
[Music]
gooses son following in his dad's
footsteps and will be played by miles
teller he's very dedicated actor really
cares very committed and I think he's
just he's gonna be amazing
he flies like his dad it's incredibly
difficult half the guys were still
puking even up until their last day he
grows a stache like his dad I felt
different people looked at me different
started walking just you know more
confident it was great and he even oils
up like his dad I've never had more oil
the oil yeah oh yeah
[Music]